how will the future of farming look like
as we near the close of 2023 the fields
of Agriculture and Technology continue
to intersect in increasingly innovative
ways transforming the way we grow and
harvest our food one of the most
groundbreaking developments in this
sphere is the rise of high-tech green
houses a revolution that's changing the
game for Farmers around the world
consider Japan where an aging Workforce
and declining population have
significantly impacted the agriculture
industry over the past decade the number
of agricultural workers in Japan has
dropped by over 20% with nearly 70% of
the remaining workers aged 65 or older
in response private companies and local
governments are now partnering to
develop smart farming Technologies with
5G playing a crucial role in this new
era of farming 5G powered robots and
remote monitoring systems are making
farming easier and more efficient these
Technologies allow experts to support
Farmers remotely reduce labor shortages
and improve profitability 5G enables
real-time transmission of large amounts
of data allowing Farmers to monitor
crops receive assistance and ensure
safety the goal is to leverage real-time
data for advanced software systems like
Ai and machine learning to provide
recommendations moving across the
Pacific to Morehead Kentucky we find app
Harvest a 60 acre indoor Farm recently
valued at over a billion dollar this
high-tech Greenhouse has just shipped
its first first harvest of organic
tomatoes on the vine to early investors
and retailers including Martha Stewart
and Walmart app Harvest uses 90% less
water than traditional farming and has
plans to open two more green houses in
the coming year the company aims to
build 15 green houses in the next 5
years revitalizing Appalachia through
high-tech farming indoor farming and
food Tech have raised over a billion
dollars in the past 5 months alone
indicating a strong interest and
investment in the future of farming
with the rise of high-tech green houses
we're witnessing a shift in the
agriculture industry moving away from
traditional farming methods towards more
sustainable and efficient practices in
conclusion the emergence of high-tech
green houses represents a significant
Leap Forward in the farming industry by
harnessing the power of technology these
green houses are not only increasing
efficiency and productivity but also
Paving the way for a more sustainable
future it's clear that the future of
farming lies in the adoption and further
development of these Innovative
Technologies and the potential impact of
these high-tech green houses is
immense as we move forward let us keep
our eyes on this exciting Frontier for
the future of farming is here and now